[Music]
[Music]
welcome to tactics time the 2017 version
of beginner breakdown if you will with a
heavier emphasis on tactics mainly
mainly looking at we usually look at a
lot of older games and today that's
certainly going to be the case for those
of you YouTube viewers who watch our
openings explained series I highly
recommend that you check out our recent
video that we just posted on the Danish
gambit because it's very relevant to our
tactics time lecture today we're gonna
look at two games from yeah okay chess
player kind of a famous guy you may have
heard of him came from Cuba world
champion at one point and his name is
josé raúl capablanca and in both of
these games I just have to throw the
disclaimer out there he's not playing
any other world champions or elite level
players both of these are from
simultaneous matches exhibitions that
masters do in which they plays several
several amateurs at once okay and for
that reason we see him playing a gambit
line and the gambit in question is the
Danish gambit which goes as such efore
e5 pretty familiar moves now for you
kids in the class most of you would play
what move here what do you think is a
reasonable move for White Knight f3
I totally agree what is the plan usually
when we that being said Knight f3 is a
total reason totally reasonable plan and
like you're saying you want to get all
your pieces out quickly and you want to
control the center one way that we
typically control the center is by
planning for a break on d4 sometimes
prepared with a c3 sometimes not usually
like everyone in the class suggested
it's prepared with a knight f3 the
Danish gambit is something that for the
center break immediately in the hopes of
getting
attacking chances on so we're willingly
sacrificing not one pond but two ponds
for the compensation of rapid
development of our miners and I'll go
back I'm not ignoring you rapid
development of our minor pieces and a
space advantage in the form of the open
B C and D files which will all add up to
some active attacking chances yes ma'am
what did you say we've given you two
pawns will allow you to exchange this
one and now we're ahead in what yes sir
okay at the cost of two pawns so be it
let's see if capablanca can make the
most out of that through peace activity
and we're also as an exercise going to
try and identify where the passive moves
were for black okay D six with the idea
of activating which minor piece for
black the light squared Bishop Queen b3
with a direct attack on which square of
seven preventing the light squared
bishop was the second plus two this move
is that we're preventing the light
squared bishop from developing because
he will be on defending which square
well said
f7 is defended by this excellent looking
night on h6 everybody agree yeah no no
that all right the this season chess
veteran over here on my left is saying
yeah right on the rim looks kind of
silly I have to agree with you but
short-term solution to a long-term
problem let's see how it how this works
out for him some more simple developing
moves getting our King to safety we're
only one step away from getting our
might all of our miners off the back row
and already we can begin to see some of
the conversation that we've received for
giving up those pawns the conversation
of course is evident namely in this case
through this King in the center but also
by the fact that he has two minors to
develop still and we just got to get our
knight on that square that it really
wants to be on c3 so that he can
solidify White's control of the center
so as I said we need to be alert to
which moves are passive that black is
making because by identifying those we
can recognize these kinds of patterns in
our own play but we can also understand
why he gets into this horrible situation
that he gets himself into in this game
okay so here in this position he decided
to develop his LightSquared Bishop
developing a piece not too bad
was there a more active move that he
could have made maybe a fork of some
sort maybe a knight fork allowing him to
simplify right when he's ahead of
material which is something that we do
or we don't want when we're ahead of
material we do want that okay all right
and is there another small plus two that
is the night sometimes better than a
bishop in a closed position it is but
I'm yeah I'm leaving you posing the
question in a funny way
he beat ya getting the bishop for the
for the night right which might prove
helpful especially when he's up to pawns
and he's just trying to win in a to pawn
up endgame makes sense yeah okay you
understand why this move might be kind
of scary for white yeah cuz he's
attacking these two guys okay good deal
instead of seeing that as simple threat
which may have get him to get may have
allowed him to take one of White's
LightSquared attackers off the board he
owned a fence his b7 Square to develop
his bishop with a little trap right what
happens if we take that undefended b7
pawn a seat I have a feeling that you
can spot this really quick say I play
say I play the foolish Queen b7 oh you
gave me a free pawn oh no I'm gonna take
that pawn
very good yeah it's one possible way
that this could go but let's look at
let's look at what you're talking about
makes sense
anybody know the name of that tactical
idea that the rook just executed right
there okay got a nice participant nice
class participate participation today
excellent okay cool deal so we see some
of the hidden threats so maybe not so
such a bad move but more active more
direct was 94 Bishop d7 trying to set a
trap against the world champion which of
course he didn't fall for attacking the
loose or the once once defended e4 upon
twice defending the e4 pawn imaginably
castling to safety who wants what side
and at this point raise your hand if you
want white if you want white here
alright my attackers like white here
okay
okay talking about something I was
talking about last night aron
nimzowitsch some of you guys may have
heard of him I know Jason definitely has
famous author of my system is famous for
saying a lot of funny things a lot of
funny Maxim's and rules of thumb about
chess and one of them that he is famous
for not saying is that especially in
these efore lines the knight on c3 has a
moral obligation to occupy the square d5
at the first opportunity achieving some
of the goals that Adriana set out for us
at the beginning here namely control of
the center through occupation and use of
our miners and here it's just super
strong right that night's going to d5
with force with a pretty obvious threat
which black is able to avoid
but at the cost of a temple in a
developing move giving white yet another
free move and one thing that it's
occurring to me that I should have
pointed out to you guys I want you to
tell me you all raise your hand after
black castle long on the King on the
Queen side after black castle long what
was what was the most obvious bad thing
about that move that we were putting the
King on a file on the same file as the
enemy Queen yes is more after fulfilling
his moral obligation and clearing a
space on the see file
wide is able to accentuate that weakness
or emphasize it by putting yet another
heavy piece on the C file directly
opposed to Black's vulnerable looking
King looking more and more vulnerable as
this game goes on all the cost of a few
passive moves after being greedy in the
opening 94 what are some of his ideas
here do we think black blacks ideas 93
and what if fe am I missing some fancy
tactic are we just forgetting about this
guy so or maybe I misheard you
you said 93 or did you say something
else okay so sometimes it's cool umm
this time might might not might be might
be a bit dubious yes sir
[Music]
95 is not bad at all
aaseesh what do you think queen h5 is
the kind of idea that I'm looking for
and the one that to me makes the most
sense of this Knight g4 move not to
mention he's just getting his night off
the rim because like they say it looks
pretty burning dim pretty grim right
there right so he wants to centralize
his night but one hidden threat in that
position might be the idea of getting
the Queen to h5
and the night to d4 yes yes yes
how does let's say RoboCup of lanka
react to that with an attack of his own
of course his pieces are better placed
more active he's just like tonight was
obligated to go to d5 when you're when
the center is open your pieces are more
developed are you obligated to resign
run away
play passive or play active great yes
thank you yes all right
so we see the Queen h5 idea and the
simple refutation of h3 taking the night
so honestly not too horrible horrible of
a square B 5 which is why we're gonna
concede our our bishop pair for it
because we just don't want that guy
there and we can also understand without
too much thought why he would capture
with the pawn and not with the night
what's one just simple reason that we
can identify without calculating the
sefa held is open right you're gonna
take off one of the pieces in between
two heavies and your King not not
without good reason
97 check 90 Oh 97 check is coming you're
on you're all over it going too slow no
okay now do you sit 97 check answered by
King B 8
and I see six speak your mind yeah no
okay okay can we already start to see
the outlines of some tactical threats
what's that is white going to mate he's
going to threaten Maiden I believe black
resigns before we see it on the board
and of course will will spell it well
we'll follow it all the way through but
yeah we got a mating attack going which
is why I'm gonna slow down a bit
excuse me he isn't Czech forced capture
did we only have are we obligated to
capture with the bishop or is it just a
good decision it's just a good chess
decision yeah why why is this move
dubious or doubtful depending on what
kind of ridiculous defense he does if he
just throws away bishop before something
like that right yeah all right so the
young man is pointing out what we're
what we're talking about that Bishop
takes c6 is far more reasonable because
this is just walking you into some
pretty obvious mating threads right and
here there aren't many effective
blockers are there alright so I think
that's what you had in mind
right okay excellent
so we understand by opening the same
file that our King is on is typically a
bad idea
either way rook a b-1 still pretty
killer move right
what are some of our ideas here I'm
gonna make the move for black this is
the move made in the game Bishop c5 a
little bit more reasonable
Bishop a6 is pretty solid except I
believe if I'm not mistaken I'm still
going to lose material but there might
be some defenses to it let's hear some
other ideas before we start looking at
any of them I'm gonna go with Adriana
first yes Bishop f7 devious what are you
trying to threaten there yes so the
young man as has a tactical idea here
but say I don't take then we'll we might
know we're still Russian but we might
have to rethink our plan right
no yeah we have another follow-up here
maybe okay on the right track I have to
say yeah this is still pretty crushing
like he's gonna he's gonna kind of make
it work for it he's gonna try to
clearly exploiting wit where's the pin
obvious yeah awesome
okay brutal so we can almost say that
after this move Queen e8 there are a
whole lot of winning chances right whole
lot of winning moves Capablanca over the
also strong looking ideas Bishop f7 and
Bishop a6 chose Bishop b5 in Adrianna
Bishop e6 I think we might just be
overlooking the fact that the Queen can
just recapture on e6 okay Bishop b5 bill
accomplishes a lot of the exploitation
of this pin b-pawn and our pressure
along the B and C files that the other
moves did but arguably in a slightly
slightly more effective way perhaps um
you know what I have to concede is in
the spirit of objectivity Bishop a6 I
believe that might be strongest but uh
I'm still pretty impressed they called
the Blanca in 1911 um probably played
the sense doing he was probably
blindfolded and playing you know five or
ten other games at the same time this
should be five being responded to in a
very passive way with Bishop d6 and just
because of all the previous analysis of
the last two moves two or three
positions I know that all of this makes
sense to you guys maybe right easy and
here black resigned in question as to
why or is that does this look resign
able to you yeah everyone here okay
hopefully we got our fill of tactics and
you know crazy gambit opening Theory
learned a little bit about controlling
the center the difference between active
moves and passive moves if you watched
it online hit like share subscribe again
thanks to all of you have a good night
[Music]